bonjour je vais parler avec un air
dramatique pendant toute la vidéo c'est
faux aujourd'hui on va parler d'un truc
assez sérieux mais vous allez voir
pourquoi je tenais à vous en parler et
vous en faites pas je vais pas faire de
discours bateau est chiant j'ai vraiment
envie de vous apprendre des choses et de
vous expliquer un petit mon point de vue
là dessus et que ce soit enrichissante
pour tout le monde
il ya plusieurs jours j'ai reçu un mail
d'une association qu'une maman avait
contacté parce que sa fille s'est
retrouvée dans l'une de mes vidéos où je
réagis à des vidéos malaise ou qui font
rire ou ce cap d'agde vous voulez en
fait c'est une association que tu peux
appeler quand il ya un problème
quelconque avec ton enfant et que tu
sais pas trop comment gérer et apportent
de l'aide là dessus et la maman a dit
l'association que depuis que sa fille
s'est retrouvée sur internet
elle était un peu en dépression alors
bien sûr c'est une vidéo qui avait déjà
fait un buzz de ouf sur internet c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle s'est
retrouvée dans ma vidéo mais je suis pas
pardonnable pour autant dans le sens où
j'ai quand même donner de l'importance à
cette vidéo et ça a quand même fait
découvert cette vidéo à des personnes
qui ne l'avait pas vu donc je m'en veux
voilà tout simplement et je tenais à
m'excuser à cette personne et à sa maman
on a fait ce qu'il fallait pour que ça
aille mieux c'est entièrement ma faute
j'ai pas été responsable j'ai pas pris
conscience de l'impact que ça pouvait
avoir sur la vie de quelqu'un de le
mettre dans sa vidéo et j'ai surtout pas
pris conscience du comportement que
certaines personnes pouvaient avoir
vis-à-vis des vidéos de ce genre voilà
ça c'est pour la partie badens c est ce
qui fait que je vous parle de ça
aujourd'hui là où je veux en venir c'est
que sur internet il ya pas mal de vidéos
ou des gens sondés dans des situations
un peu humiliant tout ou des situations
dans laquelle on n'a pas envie d'être
et c'est ça qui rend le truc drôle c'est
la situation ok donc on regarde la vidéo
ça nous fait marrer on se dit [ __ ]
c'est trop drôle la situation et épique
il ya toujours un événement tu t'y
attends pas et ça tue encore plus marrer
bref y'a des gens qui en voyant ces
vidéos là vont juste se marrer et passer
à d'autres vidéos
voilà c'est des gens comme moi des gens
comme l'un d'entre vous c'est sûr mais
il ya des gens qui ont besoin en plus de
rire devant la vidéo d'aller voir la
personne et de se moquer d'elle en
direct de l'insulté de lui dire tu es
moche ont des trucs gratuits qui nous
sommes et ça aucun sens de faire ça
voire même de retrouver la personne dans
la vraie vie et poster des lettres dans
sa boîte aux lettres de toqués de se
moquer de casser une vie de la maison
enfin ça peut aller vraiment super loin
c'est ce qu'on appelle du harcèlement
voilà les gens qui ont besoin
après avoir vu une vidéo d'à les
harceler la personne alors je voulais
vous dire déjà que je cautionne pas du
tout ce genre de comportement que si les
gens d'entre vous ont fait ça et bien
franchement
vous avez déconner et ne leur fait plus
jamais vous n'avez aucune idée de
l'impact que cela peut avoir sur la vie
de quelqu'un parce que vous n'êtes pas
seuls à le faire il ya plein de gens qui
vont faire danser une personne deux
personnes trois personnes quitte envoie
une petite insulte un petit message du
mignon ça fait chier mais tu passes au
dollar quand ça commence à être des
centaines de personnes tous les jours
sur une durée très longue
l'at-on moral commence à être
sérieusement affectée et ça amène des
gens au suicide
je reçois chaque semaine des mails de
gens qui sont en réelle des pressions
alors qu'ils ont 11 12 13 15 ans 16 ans
et ils sont des pressions comme un
adulte de 40 ans fait quand il a vécu
énormément de choses là on parle quand
même d'un adolescent et qui en sont
arrivés là
juste parce que des gens les les
recèlent en fait du coup je suis pas
psychologue j'suis pas assistant social
je peux pas faire du cas par cas
vis-à-vis de ça et je préfère faire de
la prévention comme je fais la queue
agir quand c'est trop tard en fait pour
faire prendre conscience aux gens de ce
que c'est le harcèlement avant que eux
mêmes deviennent des harceleurs sans
même s'en rendre compte
pour certains la frontière entre les
petits clash l'amusement 11 vannes et
caetera et le harcèlement
elle est un peu flou quand quelqu'un
n'est pas un ami proche de toi et que tu
te moques tous les jours de lui pour les
mêmes raisons ça a vraiment un impact
psychologique sur cette personne et il
faut s'en rendre compte c'est terrible
est ce que je trouve horrible maintenant
et j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les réseaux
sociaux pour ça c'est que c'est vraiment
rentré dans le coeur des gens en fait
ils ont vraiment besoin d'avoir un
tweeter besoin d'avoir un facebook
besoin d'avoir un état grave et partager
toute leur vie là dessus et le problème
avec ça c'est que otan ça part d'une
bonne intention je trouve les réseaux
sociaux autant les gens en ont fait un
peu n'importe quoi et j'ai l'impression
que ça fait plus de mal que de bien
aujourd'hui maintenant quelqu'un qui se
fait traquer à l'école en cours
ok il va en cours on se moque de lui
toute la journée etc il rentre chez lui
avant nos parents quand on est rentrés
chez eux ils étaient tranquilles ils
étaient dans leur petit monde y voyaient
leurs poteaux autour de etc il n'y a pas
de souci maintenant la personne qu elles
rendent elle va sur internet et des fois
le harcèlement continu sous forme de
cyber harcèlement via internet et la
personne n'est jamais tranquille vous
rendez compte tu sors de chez toi t'es
pas tranquille tu rentres chez toi tu
vas sur internet pour se changer les
idées étaient encore pas tranquille j'ai
vu les effets que cela pourrait avoir
sur la vie des gens et franchement c'est
terrible c'est terrible si vous aviez lu
ces mails que je reçois que je lis et
qu'ils me foutent le cafard et je me dis
mais [ __ ] mais comment c'est possible
sincèrement vous seriez choqué vous
seriez vraiment choqué pour revenir aux
réseaux sociaux je trouve ça terry
ce besoin de partager sa vie ce besoin
en fait ce besoin de satisfaire son ego
virtuel et un ego virtuel
il ya des battles de follower ouais je
pèse plus que toi j'ai plus de followers
et c'est la base les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas censé apporter des problèmes
c'est juste 107e mettre en relation avec
des gens qui ont les mêmes centres
d'intérêt que toi c'est censé regrouper
les gens autour de choses qu'ils aiment
bon c'est la vision utopique du truc
bien sûr ou même partager des infos
facilement par exemple en 1789 la
révolution française serait toute chose
il y avait eu huit heures ça serait fait
en deux jours il ya une capacité à se
mobiliser et à agir qui est vraiment
exceptionnel avec twitter facebook etc
c'est tarbes à regarder jérôme jarre par
exemple récemment ce qu'il a fait pour
la somalie c'est juste génial et c'est
l'illustration parfaite de ce que l'on
peut réussir à faire avec les réseaux
sociaux prenez du recul par rapport au
monde virtuel
n'oubliez jamais que c'est censé vous
apporter que du kif si quand vous allez
sur twitter facebook etc
vous subissez les choses vous êtes mal
il ya vous vous avez des gens qui
disaient tu es moche et ça vous blesse
vraiment ça vous blesse et bien arrêté
prenez du recul
allez avec vos potes que vous êtes fait
via le net allez sur skype juste avec
eux joué juste avec eux passer le temps
juste avec eux mais ne vous faites pas
de mal c'est un peu gaga ce que je dis
ou ça peut paraître un peu évident pour
certaines personnes mais croyez moi ça
ne l'est pas pour tout le monde et je
préfère le souligner parce que mine de
rien il ya beaucoup de gens qui
subissent du cyberharcèlement tous les
jours peut-être même certains sans même
se rendre compte en se disant que c'est
normal que c'est internet que mais non
c'est pas normal c'est pas parce que les
gens sont anonymes et que du coup il se
lâche complètement sur le net vis-à-vis
des autres et qu'il l'ait défonce que
c'est normal non c'est pas normal pas
normal du tout [ __ ] on devrait pas
accepter ça et dire qu'internet c'est
comme ça faut s'y faire non faut pas s'y
faire fort juste qu'on change un peu nos
comportements au nahd des gros beaufs de
merde et gris qui critique tout et qui
descendent les gens pour rien et qu'on
prenne un peu conscience des
conséquences que ça sur les autres bref
si quelqu'un autour de vous soit harcelé
et c'était pas lui apporter de l'aide
je mettrai un numéro dans la description
qui est numéro officielle contre subi du
harcèlement c'est des gens qui quittent
aides quitte conseil qui voit là
vraiment ça aide vraiment si vous êtes
dans cette situation n'hésitez pas je
suis désolé pour tous ceux qui m'ont
envoyé des mails mais je suis pas
psychologue je suis pas je sais même pas
quoi vous dire en fait ce n'est pas par
où commencer
donc je préfère agir à ma manière en
faisant de la prévention comme je fais
là et puis vous je vous redirige vers
des services ont été mis en place
qui sont très efficaces donc n'hésitez
pas à faire appel à ce service et ça va
pas bref n'acceptons pas le harcèlement
arrêtons de trouver ça normal
on peut se lâcher on peut s'envoyer des
vallons peut se marrer c'est ça qui est
bien aussi dans la vie c'est voilà ce se
vanner se cacher c'est cool mais quand
on tombe dans l'art scellement et c'est
facile de tomber dans l'art seulement ça
n'a plus rien de cool et ya des gens qui
se tuent à cause de ça je veux sortir
des chiffres il ya trois à quatre
personnes qui se suicident chaque année
à cause du harcèlement et à 22 % des
gens harceler qui n'en parle pas il y en
a aussi beaucoup qui subissent du
harcèlement et que non même pas
conscience qu'ils pensent que c'est
normal que tout le monde dans cette
situation non bref soyez sympa avec les
autres chamailler vous amusez vous
cachez vous faites ce que vous voulez
mais ne brisez pas des vies bêtement
prenez conscience de vos actes comme
aujourd'hui je prends conscience de ma
responsabilité
quand je met quelqu'un dans une vidéo et
je réagis à sa vidéo et que ça donne de
mauvaises idées à d'autres personnes et
que j'ai pas du tout devenir avec je
m'en veux à mort c'est un sujet un peu
bas dans une vidéo très loin des drôles
mais là je profite de ma notoriété pour
en parler et pour essayer de faire la
prévention vis-à-vis de ce sujet
j'espère que ça changera
au moins les choses de 5 % si on peut ce
serait cool fait attention à ce que vous
dites aux autres sur internet soyez pas
méchant gratuitement et blessant ça n'a
aucun sens d'être comme ça en face de
vous c'est des vrais êtres vivants qui
sont comme vous ça pourrait être votre
soeur votre frère votre père votre mère
en phase donc fait super gars face à
eilat je parle comme si vous étiez tous
dans ces situations mais pas du tout je
sais très bien que ça représente
minorité mais malheureusement ça suffit
à briser des vies je crois que j'ai dit
tout ce que j'avais à dire j'avais pas
trop préparé le truc comme je vous ai
dit mais bon je crois que je fais le
tour de ce que j'avais à dire je vous
dire qu'ils habitent dans une prochaine
vidéo qui sera plus amusante que
celle-ci portez vous bien prenez soin de
vous de vos amis et vos proches
et puis je vous fais plein de bisous et
à très vite